In his heyday,
would you let Alfonso me
too you in his heyday?
No man, I think I have
enough confidence to ...
What's his heyday?
Yeah. I'll go
with Jeffrey first.
Jeffrey?
Jeffrey, I'd be like hey
you know what Jeffrey,
I'm over here for a pool party.
You gonna diddle me?
I get it. It was the butler
in the pool house.
I'm having fun.
How did Tatiana Ali
not get it on that set?
Remember when she just ...
when did she become,
she got hot,
like adult hot
almost instantaneously.
Right before Kev and Kev jumped
and put her as a love interest
of his short lived sitcom.
Really?
Yeah, The Big House
I think it was called.
Yeah, she was a love interest
in it I think.
Smart. You just go
and get a girl
he had a crush on
since you were 12.
You'd be like,
what are you doing,
you want to be in a show.
And they're like, hi,
you're like yeah, yeah I know.
What do you call that
genre of black women Chris?
It's the Tatiana Ali,
Chilli from TLC falls in it.
Ooh, yes.
Like very white people
hair almost.
It's like very mainstream cute,
I don't know.
Softer features.
I don't know what they call em.
I like them.
I think it's softer features.
I mean if I'm gonna go
in that zone,
I'm gonna just slide
into Topanga area.
I like Lisa,
you know what I mean,
I liked her, Tatiana.
Lisa Turtle?
I like Lisa Turtle.
They was good but ..
Oh yeah, Lark Voorhies
same thing.
Voorhies was one.
Is this bad statements?
I was younger at the time
so I'm gonna say I liked it
when she was younger.
Is that a bad thing to say?
Who's that? Which one?
Tatiana Ali, I like her
when she was like my age.
I'm gonna say at the time.
Dude, Lark Voorhies became
a bat shit lunatic.
Oh she's crazy.
What happened to her?
I don't know.
She just went nuts.
She hacked her face all up.
So she wasn't saved by the bell?
No, the bell dropped the ball.
All of the sudden they just
started putting pictures of her
looking like a cat faced lady,
like she had too much
plastic surgery.
She went bonkers.
Her and Lil Kim smashed
their face into the same wall.
That is just nuts where people
just keep going back.
You're like stop.
By the way, 'cause all of them
have a point
where you're like perfect.
Could we do it?
But they all have a point
where you can say perfect.
Michael Jackson
Thriller, perfect.
Lil Kim ruined her face.
I was a huge Lil Kim fan.
Me too.
Don't touch it, don't touch it,
fuck,
fuck, fuck, you touched it.
You touched it too much.
Goddam it.
If you go through timelines,
I'm telling you,
it'll drive you nuts.
Lil Kim had a point,
Notorious K.I.M., stop there.
Can someone do, you know like
the black and white video
where the faces were morphing.
It's like it's black ...
they could do the Lil Kim faces.
Oh people have probably
done that already.
Yeah, has to be out there.
But whenever they do that,
they do it like meth heads too.
They'll do a really pretty girl
then she does three months
of meth, six months of meth,
then by like two years-
Then I can fuck her.
Jay's in the picture with her.
goes man
she has deteriorating quick.
Take the picture man,
I got to get her back now
while the gettin's good.
I don't know if it's a rebound
or a plummet.
This shit's going bad.
I don't know if I'm rock bottom
or on her way back to the top.
Let's just hope
it's a bounce back.
Oh shit.
Nothing on Alfonzo Riviera?
No, I found something,
he's suing
Fortnite for using
the Carlton dance.
I saw that.
Maybe that's what it was.
Hell yeah. Good for him.
Maybe he was me too'd by
Fortnite.
I'd like to know
that Carlton's litigious.
There's this video saying ...
it's a TMZ video
that says sad Michael Jackson
didn't touch him.
Get out of here.
Well of course.
Then there was a guy-
It's an ATM card.
With the same last name
that's actually a hockey player
from Canada that was accused
of assaulting the nanny.
Oh, that wasn't my thought.
You blended your hockey news
and your Carlton news.
Oh, my Carlton and hockey news,
I do read those back to back.
Yeah, you got to get
different apps for em.
Or you should not have
any Carlton news ever.
I do every day
go to Fresh Prince
where are they now's
and then the Daily Puck.
Where is Jeffrey at?
I go up and I read
the Saskatoon Gazette.
What's that?
Why is Jeffrey not killing it.
Jeffrey is killing it.
He's just spending his money.
He was already
an older guy.
You know what he's doing
right now?
Right now he's got
some reasonable sunglasses on.
He's in swimsuits-
A hot 40 year old.
Oh dude yeah, he's got a hot
40 year old
and he's just on a-
Good body, all ass.
Yeah, he's just on the patio.
Fat ass. I'm imagining this
and I like it for Jeffrey.
I'm feeling good for Jeffrey.
Of course.
He just gets noticed
occasionally at dinner.
Oh thank you, thank you.
Yes, yes, that was fun.
I talk to Will occasionally.
Oh yes, Master William would
have loved that, okay, okay.
All right good seeing you.
Okay, enjoy your meal.
Cheers. Yeah, he's
just living the life.
Alfonso? God only knows.
Jay thinks he's ...
He's all over the game
show network.
I know.
Oh they love him.
Him and Mario Lopez are just
getting younger by the day.
That was smart.
It's a smart move
on both of their parts.
Mario Lopez was like put me on
every TV in every hotel, Extra.
I tell you what, I almost forget
that he's A.C.
Slayter now
I think of him now more
as the junk advertisement
television face.
He looks worse when he was A.C.
Slayter than he does now.
He looks amazing.
It pisses me off.
Yeah, he held up great.
For some reason he's like one
of those people
who I kinda hate him.
I bet he could take
Valley now.
Absolutely.
A wrestling match.
For sure.
I'd put my money on A.C.
Good looks, bad casting on ...
have you seen the reveal
of Jigsaw on Punisher yet?
No I have not.
When they reveal it?
Well let me tell you the bummer
of this, it's a waste of time.
Why they make it
a big reveal ...
he's got a few nicks
on his gorgeous face.
This guy can get more pussy
than all of us in this room.
He's got Rambo face.
If he had double the amount
of scars he has.
Didn't they do Jigsaw in one of
the incarnations of Punisher
and he was like
all super fucking cut up?
He's supposed to be a face
like a jigsaw puzzle.
It's not Jigsaw-ly at all,
it's ...
You know what, go ahead and blow
it for me, you can spoil it.
It looks like he got attacked
with a tiger lady.
Not even.
'Cause what you said he goes,
oh I gashed my cheek.
Yeah, his face was smashed
into a mirror to oblivion.
If we could look up
all the Jigsaws
'cause I know there's one there
where they did it fucked up
and I think it was
the one with Thomas Jane?
Yeah dude this was terrible.
Or the one after that?
I mean Punisher's great, so far.
I love the character
and the guy-
Yeah, I watched the whole thing.
I'm on episode five-
Look at that.
Yes, that's what
it's supposed to be.
You're supposed to throw up
a little bit in your mouth
when you look at it.
You're supposed to see him,
that's what I thought
they were coming with.
I'm gonna be honest,
this guy is still sexy.
I ain't gonna lie,
he's still sexy.
Please bring it up.
Sexy scars.
Yeah, everyone's
an interesting story
about something masculine
he's done.
Yeah dude, honestly
I didn't even think ...
I don't know.
Can you bring it up?
Yeah, I'm trying to find one
that shows it straight on.
Just do reveal.
If you can even see it.
Just do Jigsaw reveal Punisher.
See that's what it should
look like.
It should look like all cut up,
Frankenstein.
Also the thing is why
he's so furious too,
one of the things
he's very narcissistic.
And it was that he was a good
looking guy who's now hideous.
And now they've made him
a good looking guy
who looks exactly the same
with some battle scars.
That's what he looks like.
What?
Get him way close if you want.
It doesn't make any difference.
He's still like head
turning-ly sexy.
Dude that's hot.
He looks like he didn't
break a mirror.
If I were Punisher and he showed
up like that I'd be like
I didn't do my job well.
What are you mad about?
I say you paid a minimum price.
You won't have to buy a beer.
You have to tell one story
and you'll never have to
buy a beer again.
You're mad at me?
You hot ...
The girls who didn't want
to fuck you,
they thought you were cocky,
now think you're vulnerable.
He's like why did you make me,
make you more fuckable?
Punisher, that's what makes
Punisher angrier.
No!
You're eating the pussy
all over town.
I told then you knew my family
and now he's more fuckable.
He murdered my family.
He fucked the FBI chick.
It's Lewis as Punisher?
Yeah, I don't know,
I don't do anything else.
He's not a real ass dude
anymore.
Yeah dude
I'm really disappointed.
That should be,
if you could screen grab that,
the one on the left
should easily be ...
It's crazy disappointing.
But you know what,
it does follow suit.
Yesterday Chris
we were talking about
how Marvel makes all their main
characters shave their chest.
In all Marvel movies.
If you notice in Punisher,
I noticed in Punisher
and we all ended up agreeing,
we noticed that you could see
he's stubbly all over his body
because he shaves
his body hair.
Two things, first of all you're
focusing on the wrong thing.
There's a story line.
It was a sex scene.
Oh I mean I'm not looking
at his chest.
Are you like old school
homophobic
where the second there's
a man's body on you're all ...
Oh hell no.
I'm looking to the sky.
Dicks in the room.
I'm a grown ass man,
I'll change my own damn wound.
No!
Mother fucker walking
around dick all willy nilly.
Sensual ass mother fucker
sneaking up on me.
Pretty ass mother fucker.
Story line taking it all sexual.
I ain't looking at Punisher's
chest hairs.
There's a bitch
over his shoulder.
I ain't gonna lie, I was looking
at the bitch
over the shoulder
the whole time.
I never even noticed
his chest hair.
She does a kiss up his belly
and you just notice
that his whole body
is not even recently shaved.
It's just stubbly,
it's that stubbly?
Yeah. It comes in stubbly.
Can you bring it up?
Yeah, bring that up.
Bring up the sex scene.
Look who wants to see
the parts of kissable stomach.
I'm not looking
at a man's stubble.
I just didn't notice
the stubble.
I get it, you just need
to be led there.
Christine, here's when I know me
and you are not fully connected
yet on our wavelengths.
Right there when he goes
I'll look at it, I'll see it.
If you should just put up
a video of a guy's huge honker
flopping around,
would've been the funniest
thing to see Chris ...
and then eventually go,
oh hell no.
I'm a grown ass man
I'll wait in the lobby.